and I got her name saved up on my phone
is Queen
oh DC Young Fly speaks out for the first
time since the death of his longtime
partner Miss Jackie O in a statement to
people the Wild and out star and his
family say quote we thank everyone for
their well wishes and ask for privacy
during this difficult time she's more
goofy than me
what are you laughing at Jackie O's
death was confirmed by bet the parent
company behind Wild 'n out on June 1st
according to TMZ she died in Miami and
no other details about her cause of
death have been released the TV
personality was 32 years old let's give
a round of applause for Jackie O for
being such a good sport
Jackie O and DC Young Fly met in 2015
the same year that he made his first
appearance on wild and out
when it comes
[Music]
when it comes it had a wild an outfit
the pair has three kids together Nova
Nala and Prince Nehemiah
bet shared their condolences to DC and
their family calling Jackie a talented
star whose impact will be forever
treasured and missed because I'm a bit
of a rebel when it comes to this because
I'm a vet so I don't really follow the
rules quote Jackie O was a loving friend
and beloved colleague of the wild and
Outcast throughout Five Seasons more
importantly she was a tremendous mother
to three beautiful children
[Music]
oh